un coup du chapeau de grégory lefort
capitaine du fc versailles auteur
notamment de cette tête décroisée il
dicte warnet 3 buts à 1 face à
saint-ouen l'aumône une troisième place
consolidée en division d'honneur et le
dossier championnat est rangé au placard
pour une semaine au menu de dimanche
prochain la prestigieuse coupe de france
et un sixième tour face aux lilas avec
tous ces ingrédients versailles se
prépare au mieux pour ce soir on a un
peu mieux géré la deuxième période mais
c'était important de gagner
on a les quatre points donc maintenant
un place à ce feu match de coupe de
france sans se mettre trop de pression
mais c'est vrai que c'est un objectif
le club a pris goût ces dernières
saisons à vivre de belles émotions et on
souhaite pouvoir aller le plus loin
possible
les bleus sont les derniers rescapés du
département dans cette édition 2013 et
franck bentolila mesure bien la tente
autour de ce match
ces rencontres de coupe toujours à part
qu'il faut gérer dès le début de la
semaine dans la préparation et la
gestion de la pression je sens bien le
petit peu non pas la pression mais ce
que ça suscite au sein du club aussi
bien de la part des dirigeants des
enfants qu'on est
la municipalité c'est vrai que c'est un
certain engouement ça montre a forcément
au filet au fil des jours mais on va
rester dans notre notre philosophie de
travail et puis peut-être un d'abord un
petit peu les tirs au but vendredi soir
dans les séances
mais c'est essentiellement l'état
d'esprit ce qu'on va y mettre pour
remporter ce match couperet puisque il
n'y a pas de point il ya juste un
vainqueur et un et un éliminé dimanche
prochain une élimination que versailles
fera tout pour éviter